we're going to begin before you do any
and all math studies we need to have
sort of a lay of the land of this topic
in works okay so I'm gonna give you a
few dots points so you know okay what
are the rough kind of things we're going
to go through so that um you kind of are
tracking us in terms of the progress
through the course and also how it
relates to the integration we already
know so where are we going to begin
first is with the extension of three
things you already know that we've just
spent some time doing okay namely
integrating mr. you actually do a few
trig functions right so trig functions
we've already been doing this right but
often if we want to make it harder in a
two-unit extension one context will give
you something which is a bit more tricky
it's more complicated this Constance of
cultures that flying around and then
we'll say okay differentiate this hence
integrate that right and so they give
you a bit of a clue in extension tooth
will give us at so much time in these
that you will start to recognize oh I
know what this one is without being
given the clue in a similar way when we
were doing that graphing question first
thing this morning you're like oh okay I
don't necessarily need all the hints
that this question is going to give me
and when extension one turns into
extension to what they start to do is
progressively take away his so firstly
trig functions are secondly inverse trig
functions its thirdly this is one now I
will say last but that all of the things
that you will look at in these three
headings which are the first exercises
basically they're things that the
extensions wants to do keep a little bit
excuse me can't do we have a little bit
of guidance and support okay but like I
said with the extensions you think I
don't you're gonna have a lot less
written on the page for a paper and
you're gonna
so there's the first three point second
quarter is we're gonna back borrow
something we developed under polynomials
which is to say okay if you have
something which is on a rational
function often when it's given to you
it's not in like a nice F dash on M form
or it's not gonna leave nicely by itself
into a chemistry Club
you've got to muck around with a little
bit and partial fractions which if you
recall it was about taking one big
fraction if you factor in the
denominator you break it up into a bunch
of cuts the partial fractions okay that
can help us with the integration of
whole order and I kind of alluded to
what we're doing polymers luster but
we're actually gonna properly do it
after that we're gonna go to this this
sort of connects to this because you
generally had every long we're also
gonna look at T result together which
again is something we know from the
context of extension of one but you can
use them for integration in the same way
that you use them for solve a trig
identities in that kind of things and
often in the best way but you sort of
combining this with this and it's a it's
a very specific kind of solving
integrals myself a teachers basically
it's just this particular substitution
and it's quite tricky so that's why it
limits the nature okay after that we've
got one one - yeah - to make pointers
that are left I hope you can see all of
the parallels I'm drawing with the
extension one and the two because this
next thing we're looking at you've done
chain rule and then we learn reverse
chain rule right so we like everyone get
back and forth between these two but we
go chamber we also know products all
right but there's no reverse product at
least there isn't in the two unit
extension ones of courses in extension -
we call the reverse chain rule
integration by parts okay an integration
by parts is trying to say okay there
must have been this this integral you're
given
it will vlog X for instance where'd that
come from well actually it came from a
product right and some part of the
product it cancelled out or you got left
with rooster log X okay it extension one
context you will say okay X hence
internet right but here they'll just
hand you the integral and they won't
give you that additional clue and
integration by parts will be our
mechanism for doing that now once you
learn integration by parts and I've
mentioned this to the first time you can
in particular what this does is it kind
of unlocks everything that was like
you're putting this category of
impossible to integrate right you can
get integrate a lot of things that are
like that and anything like it which has
powers involve like those kinds of
things squared cubed to power for about
400 if you want we can you do this
multiple times we call this a recurrence
relationship or in the context of the
course there's called recurrence
relations so it's kind of like doing
we had festivities and second
derivatives and there's no reason why
you couldn't have a third or fourth
derivative this is kind of like first
integral second integral third an
integral and you just keep on going out
however many times you want okay and
that's basically an overview of where
we're going you can see how much it
links with extension 1 integration so I
was writing your reports recently and
when things I had to say was ok
you've done to your tests you've done
one tests if they were weak this is
their in calculus you're going to fill
them a lot in this topic so if you do I
think we're gonna do this you're like
okay I'm just as confused on the routine
things tell me go back like the
fundamental something very very strong
obviously before you can take all this
does that make sense